día 108 de la guerra de rusia en ucrania
y el epicentro sigue siendo el sur y el
este de este país en particular la
localidad de severodonezk así las
autoridades ucranianas las tropas de
quiebre están teniendo dificultades para
abastecerse y esperan el envío de armas
occidentales se debieron es que es una
localidad estratégica es una de las
últimas aún en mano del ejército
ucraniano en el extremo este de este
país es pero estos más de 100 días de
conflicto también están dejando escenas
como las que pueden ver a mis espaldas
nos encontramos en uno de los pueblos
retomados cerca de quiere uno de los
pueblos que han hecho de escudo a la
capital ucraniana desde el comienzo de
la guerra en este país aquí más del 70%
de los edificios han quedado
completamente destrozados y los vecinos
están teniendo enormes dificultades para
la reconstrucción de hecho nos
comentaban que apenas cuentan con la
ayuda de algunos voluntarios que les
están ayudando a construir habitaciones
temporales de cara a uno y aquí ya se
preanuncia muy difícil